congratulations on this film you're not
the nicest guy in this film that's for
sure
uh how was it not careful
yeah no you're not the nicest guy no no
but what was it like for you to be
the villain almost
it was fun it was uh really it was a
real fun character to explore
you know this character is uh he's
impulsive
he's he's volatile he takes what he
wants what he wants
and that's a that's a you know in the
real world you're
a maniac but it's fun to explore this
character in film
yeah and to see you back with jason was
pretty awesome to see
you guys working together not really
working together but
clashing together uh how is that feeling
to be part together in
a fast state and being part of this
project together it's great you know
it's incredible
um you know first off working with guy
ritchie was
right a dream really he's in my eyes
he's one of the
one of the great directors out there and
has a style
you know totally of his own yeah so
getting to you know getting away with
him was just
i can't say enough good things yeah yeah
when you think about
jason though like he's this legendary
action star now i think would you put
him up there
with the arnolds and slides of the world
oh yeah yeah right he's he's one of the
great action stars of
of you know a film you know i put him up
there with
with all the greats yeah that's good i'm
glad you did i agree with you he's
pretty uh
pretty spectacular and there was a scene
in the movie where
you know all of it's happening and
everyone's bringing in money and they
say don't splurge on anything but it got
me thinking
when you got your first big paycheck
what was that one thing you splurged on
that's a good question i d you know i'm
not a big shopper i'm not a big
um a car a house
uh something big real estate uh
real estate for sure i was always more
interested in
and trying to find ways to invest money
um you know uh
build wealth instead of just buy stuff
and things in a car no i mean you gotta
have a car
you know but i drive to be honest i
drive a ford f-150
pickup truck nothing special you know
that's my day-to-day car
what does your dad think of the film has
you seen it yet
um uh this film no
not even out yet you gotta see it before
before he did he's your dad he gets
access to everything
well not in this case
you're ahead of him but he'd like it he
liked this film
i think he'd like it it's fun it's a fun
film
congratulations it's very similar to uh
it's a rev you know there's a revenge
theme there's it's like
outlaw josie whales if you've ever seen
that film it's a
it's an old western but it's a revenge
revenge
you